so as you know the holidays are right
around the corner so that means it's
time for holiday shopping the deal with
christmas
who are these people i need to buy gifts
for
sorry holiday season oh god
ladies and gentlemen this is always a
thrill for me a good friend of mine and
a comedy legend sometimes likes to come
by the show and try out some of his
untested material please ladies and
gentlemen welcome new material seinfeld
cereal
hello
pete how you doing good to see you new
material how are you i'm doing well just
been rehearsing some new material yeah
pete here's my question why do they call
it rehearse you do it before the thing
it should be called prehearse
then if you screw it up you rehearse all
the pre-rehearsal
you're saying it should be called
pre-rehearsal because it's it's before
well that's what i'm saying
yeah okay that's that's pretty funny i
think that'll work pre-rehearsal what's
with these steak temperatures
keep track of these things i can't rare
medium rare medium done well done i'll
tell you the only thing rare then i get
my damn steak the way i asked them to
cook it
and why is it called rare steak what is
it laced with ancient gold
they find it in some aztec temple
somewhere
they got it off a cow as far as i know
those things are all over the place
it's not rare it's everywhere
it's not rare it's everywhere yeah
we keep eating these cows they're going
to be extinct
there's a word
extinct that means it's gone
i mean when it was here it was tinged
extinct means gone when it's here it
should be instinct
how's that thing's instincts not good
it's instinct
this joke
stinks everybody